voici les chevaliers de l'huile d'olive
le signal que la dégustation peut
commencer
l'huile de l'année se marient aux
croûtons et à l'aïoli ici personne ne
veut laisser sa part aux voisins
premières impressions
elle a une belle couleur on vient d'en
rester cadiot ici uniquement d un
portable une fête ensoleillée signe du
ciel
après un mois de pluie l'huile de nyons
la seule d'origine contrôlée fait
toujours recette le premier week-end de
février l'avantagent écrasons les olives
au fur et à mesure de la récolte on
ramasse sont venus dans la journée et
dans la nuit qui suit on les écrase le
produit conserve toute sa fraîcheur
ces vitamines et sels minéraux jour de
fête pour la confrérie jour
d'intronisation pour neuf nouveaux
membres leurs promesses toujours
défendre l'olivier un arbre menacé
d'arrachage il ya quelques années mais
aujourd'hui produire de l'huile et de
nouveau rentable
au-delà du symbole provençal qui a
traversé les siennes
olivier c'est le symbole de la vie de la
lumière de la sagesse
et n'oublions pas la paix dans le bec de
la colombie a toujours le rameau
d'olivier et nous en avons bien besoin
dans le monde autour de nyons l'olivier
fait partie de l'économie locale sa
culture est en plein renouveau
vingt-cinq mille arbres seront plantés
d'ici quatre ans